man people can't see but look at this
100 pending 102 pending challenges
um so again if you want a game
just be patient send a challenge
if you're a sub you'll be more likely to
be accepted
because now it's random sub time
playing nicholas with ak
okay good luck
so i'm playing yeah i'm playing a lot of
uh seems like a lot of new players
which is nice try and teach a thing or
two
um i think i'll play if we see knight c6
i'll play a ponziani
it's one of my favorite openings to
especially to recommend for newer
players
thank you onakuce and subbing with prime
so knight f6 is the most popular move
and the whole point of the ponziani is
to
grab the center with the the center
pawns
growing your hair out uh maybe
possibly i don't know i'm just avoiding
getting a haircut
so it's kind of a byproduct
okay so now i push so one rule uh with
ponziani
whatever pawn black takes we use the
other pawn
to push forward and attack one of the
knights eric the first
blame you for people endlessly trying to
play the england
oh i'm sorry oh
but maybe not succeeding okay let's take
so it's kind of a cool position the
knights are lined up in a weird way
looks like they're about to do some like
tick-tock dance
and d6 so d6 is actually uh i think it's
the most played move on leachates
actually
but it's a very bad blunder because of
this move
bits bits bits bits bits bit spits bits
thanks tagi so the problem for black
is that black has to block the check and
both of these squares i control
more times than black so if bishop d7 i
win the queen
if pawn c6 then fun things will happen
hey it's axer typo and it was fortune
domino too
some strong scrabble players in the chat
why can't you raid me you could maybe
try and host me
but raids should work hopefully
i'm not sure but thanks for joining
just in time for the destruction
of the black is it the queen side
is just all of the pieces so now it's
uh xqc would be 75 percent proud
because it's three-fourths of a wooden
shield i think it's better for me
to take the knight if i were to take the
rook i'd lose the bishop
but um
[Music]
okay so the opening paid off
white has an extra knight and pawn
and let's see if we can get a quick win
please castle
oh yeah shout out to gary also thanks
tagi for the gary bits
i guess queen h5 is probably
yeah discouraging black from castling
but that's okay it's not bad to keep the
king in the center
especially with a half open file
bishop f8 is a good move though i'll
play queen e3
so queen e3 i'm just attacking a pawn
and doing nothing else
also thanks to people for subbing
short t sam and james part white
appreciate it
um that's actually a good move
because now if i take oh wait i i can
take the pawn
i was gonna say if i take the pawn i
lose my bishop
but then i would win a rook that's why
you always have to think
one more move ahead in chess
okay so i'm attacking the rook and now
the
queen and king are lined up nicely
so i'd like to again in some move like
rook
e1 the problem is that rook's not
defended here
eric how do you get through a losing
streak and just take a deep breath
and find find a noob
to to play and hopefully you can beat
them
and then hopefully your confidence will
be raised
so if i play rookie one
f5
the problem is the bishop's pinned if i
move the bishop i get mated
but there's a cool line rookie one f5
and then
even consider f3 but there's also bishop
g5
i don't know let's play queen d4 simpler
move
attacking the rook defending the bishop
it's hard to it's hard to keep up with
everything in chat
while trying to explain what's happening
for a minute or been working elsewhere
feels like i haven't seen you on in a
while yeah i took a small break
but now i'm back so it's nice to be back
nice to have a position like this too
[Music]
i'm not just going to keep developing
yeah so rook rook here save the rook it
prepares this
but now black can't ever castle
so all i want to do is get a rook to e1
that's all i want for christmas along
with toggy gifting subs
thanks tagi um
toggy gifting five subs to gigahertz
and now the hero24 sub z
g and lecheme
and swole oswagons appreciate that
all the new subs can use their taki
emotes
okay now we have the beloved pin
yeah the pin is mightier than the sword
oh it's a counter attack
but now it's a counter counter attack
my opponent has been putting up
resistance especially for the rating
oh and thank you uh gigahertz oh
gigahertz paying it forward
was just gifted a sub and now gifting a
sub to stan's mike
appreciate that
okay i'm going for the kill
[Music]
or at least for the winning of material
i'll play this move
so blocks and check all i'm trying to do
i'm trying to induce rook d7
so i could take it and win more stuff
but okay didn't happen
oh it's close to mate where's the mate
king d5
oh that's a fair move
so i'm pinning the pawn the bishop's
also pinned but i'm planning to take
because then the pawn can't take back
that looks very nice
okay thanks for the game nicholas
with ak um
yeah my point was just kind of a victim
of this
this very nifty trap it's it's easy to
stumble into if you're not familiar with
opening um i'll just give a quick
slow motion replay
so this is the start of the ponziani uh
we might play c3
and again i think it's very effective
for newer players because
if black plays this or this or this
uh you always reply with d4 the only
move really that you don't play d4
against is d5 after which you play queen
a4
i think i played this against vanguard
uh
the video is on youtube if you search
for ponziani
uh on my channel
so in this line um
yeah knight takes e4 is the second most
popular
and then then we went into
kind of this main line if black takes
this way then there's this move
whoa it's wasabi gifting subs thanks for
seeing
i'll read off the names but i want to
just finish some some instruction
so after e5 the main line is knight d5
i'd like to recommend the move queen b3
here
knight b6 and then takes objectively
it's close to equal
but for my experience it's more pleasant
to play for white
especially for newer players too
and yeah the trap that we walked into
that black walked into
is really just some the most popular
line
like d6 has been played 3 500 times
uh the best move here is knight g6
um but after d6 it's uh
it's hard to recover from this
and there's actually a cool line which
we didn't get into the in in the game
but i'll show it anyways
is after c6 takes if black were to take
the knight
then white's making another queen a
bishop here we take
and we have two queens and the flag
takes the queen we meet
so it's a cool line um i might put that
on youtube
i feel like people like the ponziani and
i don't have enough
ponziani content so youtube people if
you made it this far
uh follow on twitch say hi to tagi
and say hi to 14 months one dumb hick
and waseem and everyone else in the chat
did you know that there is an under
promotion buried in one of the line of
the tracks
i did not okay yeah say hi to twitch
chat that was me you just played thank
you so much for the lesson
oh my pleasure playing back in september
and i'm still learning
oh it's september oh wow oh that's
awesome
[Music]
i'll keep it up in your chest journey
and yeah very important when you're
first starting to take every
loss as a lesson